It's God who died like that for some reason
He went to the afterlife
[music]
And there he reunited with his father, who had died earlier, and was informed of the truth by the father himself.
No, where in the other world do you know without knowing that?
It's not that she killed her, but that she was killed by her father. She's a ghost who goes on a rampage because she wants her beard donated
.
Karin Nanase.
Thinking of her pretty figure, the one who will take away the enlightenment is the public figure Nanase, who will surely
leave the night.
Let's send them back to the store It
seems there are a lot of Orin-chans It
was a story that changed the image of summer as a public figure
But I understand your father's feelings
ana
I'm not weak